Hoje a gente vai falar um pouquinho
sobre saúde do Futuro certo então vamos
entender um pouquinho sobre o que que é
saúde que é esse estado de completo
bem-estar biopsicossocial e não apenas a
ausência de doenças essa definição de
1946 do período pós-guerra da da
história da humanidade ela foi dada
devido ao conceito de que saúde não faz
parte só do nosso corpo ele faz parte
também o nosso contexto que nos cerca
agora esse estado de completo bem-estar
biopsicossocial me parece só um momento
aonde talvez nem a Gisele Bündchen
consiga viver muitos deles certo na
verdade o que a gente fala sobre saúde é
um equilíbrio entre as partes do corpo
da mente e daquilo que nos cerca e é
isso que determina a
a forma como a gente vive é interessante
a gente vê que quando a gente fala sobre
vida consequentemente nós estamos
falando sobre a morte e quando a gente
entende Quais são os principais fatores
que fazem com que as pessoas morreram ao
redor do mundo nós entendemos as
consequências do nosso estilo de vida e
Atualmente as principais causas de morte
no mundo são devido a doenças
cardiovasculares como o coração como
infarto do coração eo derrame doenças
pulmonares câncer o diabetes e ainda
algumas doenças infecciosas
Principalmente nos países em
desenvolvimento é um fato que nós Já
conseguimos diminuir muito mortalidade
infantil e óbito por outras infecções
nos Palmas vemos vimos lutando durante
muito tempo ao longo da história da
humanidade O que são boas notícias mas o
fato é que hoje nós estamos morrendo
devido ao nosso estilo de vida é isso
que acontece quando
a criar ambientes que construímos para
viver nessa velocidade o nessa
produtividade o nessa insanidade aonde
tudo passa a ser um grande grande
confusão e nós não iremos naquilo que
realmente importa que a forma como a
gente vive E aí veio a pandemia do
coronavírus em 2020 o mundo inteiro
parou e nós tivemos que observar o mundo
através das janelas de nossas casas o
mundo pode ter parado mas a vida não
parou e na verdade nós podemos assistir
da janela da nossa casa um dos
principais ganhos da ciência aonde houve
uma evolução tecnológica de comunicação
de compartilhamento de dados que
permitiu a um mundo desenvolver uma
vacina em menos de 12
e da descoberta de um novo vírus e isso
é um ganho gigantesco para a humanidade
O mundo nunca foi tão rápido e ele nunca
mais vai ser mais devagar mas o que a
gente fez nesses 12 meses como
humanidade é uma grande Façanha da
ciência mas ao mesmo tempo nós
assistimos também de Camarote o colapso
do sistema de saúde de todos os países
que sofreram com a premia todos aqueles
que não souberam trabalhar com a
prevenção e entendendo o indivíduo no
seu comportamento sofreram um verdadeiro
colapso estrutural físico e mental dos
sistemas de saúde e nós passamos a
entender de uma forma um pouco dura mas
que é verdade saúde não é sobre mim
saúde é sobre todos nós e nós já
sabíamos muito bem disso
em fins da década de década de 40 Nós
estudamos sobre os determinantes sociais
de saúde e nós sabemos que na verdade os
nossos fatores genéticos correspondem
apenas a trinta por cento do resultado
da nossa saúde para fatores como sexo
idade e até fatores hereditários como a
genética da nossa família não são os
grandes responsáveis por dizer como nós
vamos viver e nem quanto nós vamos viver
o que realmente determina a forma como
nós vamos viver são os nossos hábitos o
nosso estilo de vida e o nosso estilo de
vida é inteiramente influenciado pela
comunidade que nos cerca por onde nós
vivemos que inteiramente influenciando
também pelos lugares onde a gente
trabalha pelo acesso ao tipo de
alimentação que nós temos o ti
o trabalho se temos trabalho a qualidade
da água a qualidade do ar o acesso aos
Serviços de Saúde tudo isso são
determinantes sociais que exercem uma
função muito grande na nossa expressão
de saúde e correspondem a setenta por
cento do resultado dela e a pandemia do
coronavírus nos ensinou muitas coisas e
uma delas é que a gente pode considerar
sim um fator de risco o Sepe aonde você
mora é isso mesmo depende do país
depende do bairro depende da cidade
depende da quadra depende do seu
apartamento é ele que determina Qual é o
ciclo que te cerca e quais são as
influências que vão fazer os setenta por
cento de influência dentro do seu corpo
e aí a gente começa a se perguntar
ou será que a gente está entregando
saúde da forma como a gente precisa e a
onde as pessoas estão Talvez seja uma
oportunidade nesse momento da gente
pensar numa nova forma de construir o
futuro que a gente deseja porque essa é
a melhor forma que nós temos de prever o
futuro tá na hora da gente trazer à
saúde de volta para casa tá na hora de a
gente começar a entender que saúde é uma
um contexto muito mais amplo do que
simplesmente médicos hospitais tá na
hora de a gente assumir uma
responsabilidade de criar um novo
ecossistema um ecossistema que une
grandes players e que coloca a saúde do
usuário como Ponto Central não dentro do
seu contexto e como fornecedor mas
dentro do contexto de vida e de
Bom dia de cada uma das pessoas a gente
precisa unir no mínimo três grandes
grupos o primeiro é a parte da
construção nós precisamos construir
ambientes mais saudáveis e que
incentivem as pessoas a terem hábitos de
vida melhor a gente tem uma enxurrada de
novas tecnologias que permitem a gente
fazer as mesmas coisas de forma
diferente Ou até influenciaram novos
tipos de comportamento e precisamos ter
um pouco de cuidado aqui porque essa
influência pode ser positiva ou negativa
Assim como nós já vimos outras
tecnologias sejam incorporadas mas é um
fato elas estão aí e elas podem ajudar e
a gente também precisa que o mercado de
saúde entenda que existe uma nova forma
de entregar saúde e essa forma ela
precisa entender como faz para
incorporar itens no Bem Estar do dia a
dia das pessoas
e para que os hábitos mais saudáveis e o
equilíbrio entre o bio-psico e o social
possa existir não de uma forma utópica
mas esse equilíbrio no dia a dia mesmo
das pessoas Então a gente tem alguns
pilares do bem-estar que consideram o o
bem-estar físico o bem-estar mental
emocional e intelectual o bem-estar do
ambiente eles precisam estar
incorporados dentro dos projetos de
Tecnologia de construção e de saúde para
que a gente possa entregar a para que a
gente possa entregar itens muito mais
satisfatórios para os nossos
consumidores né o mercado de construção
civil precisa assumir uma certa
responsabilidade saúde não é mais só
responsabilidade do governo os governos
também sejam responsáveis por planejar
as cidades Mas quem as constrói são os
incorporadores e os
as cores que precisam assumir um
protagonismo e tentar trazer o futuro
que a gente quer construir nós
precisamos entregar ambientes que tragam
a sustentabilidade o verde calçadas
lugares que possa a gente possa caminhar
que possa comer comida local que as
gerações possam conviver entre elas
esses bolsões residenciais ou esses bons
sonhos e comerciais que não se conversam
fazem que o que o mundo separado fique
completamente isolado e nós precisamos
trazer muito mais preocupação na
construção não só do Muro para dentro
mas também do Muro para fora de uma
cidade que se torne mais agradável uma
cidade que seja mais saudável E para
isso nós precisamos das mãos dos
construtores
e nós precisamos também falar um
pouquinho sobre a parte de tecnologia a
responsabilidade desse tipo de
ferramenta
e a responsabilidade sobre esse tipo de
ferramenta dentro da casa das pessoas
permite com que a gente entenda hábitos
e auxilia hábitos de uma forma muito
positiva e também Levanta a questão de
dados e de sigilo e de individualidade
que precisa ser contemplada mas é um
fato que ela vai sair incorporada dentro
da casa das pessoas com focam e levar
mais saúde e bem-estar para o dia a dia
delas
bom e nós temos também a parte da saúde
que é um dos grandes players que se não
entender que a saúde vai voltar de volta
para casa e que nós podemos fazer parte
do dia a dia das pessoas nós vamos estar
perdendo uma grande oportunidade de
oferecer à saúde mais humanizada que
podemos no futuro eu gosto de falar que
saúde é tempo com qualidade quando a
gente faz aniversário todo mundo deseja
para a gente saúde eles tão falando
assim viva bastante mas fica bem e eu
acho que a gente precisa pensar como que
nós como médicos podemos fazer parte do
dia a dia das pessoas e não as pessoas
tentarem entrar nas nossas rotinas
médicas de exames e de hospitais como a
gente faz Para incorporar os nossos
tratamentos as nossas orientações e nos
capacitar cada vez mais para entender o
hábito de vida das pessoas
a fazer parte do dia a dia da tomada de
decisão daquele micro momento aonde a
gente sabe que eu tô cuidando da minha
saúde tanto da minha saúde e da minha
doença ao mesmo tempo e é isso que nós
precisamos incorporar e usar a
telemedicina como uma excelente
ferramenta que não só nos conectar com
os nossos pacientes mas que nos mostra a
realidade que nós tanto fugimos ao longo
dos anos é muito mais fácil atender o
paciente dentro do nosso contexto dentro
do nosso consultório mas quando a gente
entende Qual é todas as que eles fatores
externos que estão influenciando na vida
deles aí sim a gente consegue levar uma
saúde humanizada do futuro então agora a
gente está nas nossas mãos construir
esse futuro que a gente deseja cabe a
nós entendermos como nós vamos nos
posicionar diante dessa oportunidade de
reescrever a nossa história e eu não
tenho dúvidas que se
Ah tá os Players em prol de uma razão da
qual todos nós estamos buscando nesse
momento quer viver mais viver melhor e
ter tempo com qualidade eu tenho certeza
que todos estarão em prol da busca de
produtos muito melhores de serviços
muito mais eficientes e de uma conexão
real com todos aqueles que precisam da
gente obrigado